so for this week uh we're going to be
talking about a Bayesian perspective on
meta learning and today's lecture is
going to be a little bit different than
um a lot of the lectures we've had so
far because we're really not going to be
talking that much about Metal learning
in this lecture we're going to be
talking about uh doing approximate
Bayesian inference via variational
inference and the reason why we're going
to talk about that today is that it will
be a lot of really useful background
knowledge for understanding Bayesian
metal learning algorithms and it's also
pretty useful outside of metal learning
algorithms as well and so we'll see a
little bit of motivation for why these
things matter in the context of meta
learning and we'll talk a lot about
Bayesian metal learning on Wednesday but
today we're going to go over some of the
um some kind of really fundamentals on
how to do uh Bayesian inference with
more complex distribution classes
awesome um So the plan for today is to
talk about a class of probabilistic
models called latent variable models
then we're going to talk about how to
actually train these latent variable
models with variational inference
then we'll talk about something called
amortized variational inference which
will address a key shortcoming of trying
to do
non-amortized variational inference and
then we'll cover a couple example Latin
variable models
um so the goals of today will be to
understand how these latent variable
models work including in deep learning
settings and also understand how to use
variational inference in order to train
these models
um also the
um some of the stuff will be useful for
doing the optional homework for there
will be it will be kind of really themed
about one of the questions will be
themed on Bayesian meta learning but one
of the derivations in that homework will
be we'll draw upon some of the ideas
that we talk about today
cool
um so let's get started by talking about
probabilistic models uh so
in probabilistic modeling we want to
model some distribution so for example
we may have some distribution P of X
where we have samples from that
distribution we have some example data
points and we want to formulate a
probabilistic model that can generate
those data points or evaluate the
likelihood of those data points so for
example we might try to fit a gaussian
model to these data points and that
would allow us to generate other
executive points like that or generally
model the distribution over those data
points
um similarly we might have a conditional
problem probability distribution that we
want to model where this won't be over
the examples we'll actually be
conditioning on one variable in order to
try to formulate a probabilistic model
of another random variable
and we've already seen examples of
conditional probabilistic models in this
course for example trying to predict a
distribution over the labels given the
input and most commonly you'll view
you'll be looking at things like
probability values over a discrete
categorical distribution or outputting
the median variance of a gaussian
distribution
um and so instead of actually literally
outputting the label why we often
actually output the values of a
probability distribution and so that's
what the kind of the the logits are
um but of course it doesn't have to
necessarily be a categorical
distribution or a gaussian distribution
um those are extremely common in the
literature but there are all sorts of
other distributions that we might want
to formulate and there's things that are
much more expressive than categorical or
gaussian distributions
um now when we want to go about training
a probabilistic model
um we will
uh formulate our our model so it could
be P Theta if x could be P Theta of Y
given X we have data for
um
data kind of from that we're assuming to
be from that distribution that we want
to be able to model
and typically we will formulate a
maximum likelihood objective where our
goal is to find the model
um for which it maximizes the likelihood
of the data and this will be kind of
arguably the best fit for the data that
we have observed
um so this sort of objective is very
easy to evaluate and differentiate for
categorical distributions and gaussian
distributions which is one of the
reasons why we often use categorical and
gaussian distributions
and this maximum likelihood objective
corresponds to the cross-entropy loss
and the mean squared error loss that we
that we all use and like
um so really the goal of this lecture is
to try to go beyond categorical or
gaussian distributions and try to model
and train more complex distributions
foreign
so why might we want to train something
more complex so maybe we want to instead
of training a normal distribution we
want to train a paranormal distribution
uh or instead of
um generating like a label maybe you
want you want to generate an image or we
want to generate text or video or
something like that
or maybe or and here's an example of a
video generative model so we might want
to generate video of an HD video
an HD video of riding a horse in the
park at Sunrise and we don't just want
it to give us one video we want to give
us kind of a range of videos that
capture that description
um another example of a more complex
scenario we might want a more complex
distribution is we want to represent
uncertainty over labels maybe there's
some ambiguity arising from limited data
or some partial observability and it may
be that our the true distribution over
the labels may not be a unimodal
distribution it may be a multimodal
distribution that's difficult to capture
with a gaussian distribution or a
categorical distribution
um and second we may also want to
represent uncertainty over functions
rather than just uncertainty over
examples or over labels
um now what do I mean by that well
in metal learning we have been
representing
um essentially Point estimates of
distributions over functions so we've
often been trying to estimate what are
our task specific parameters given a
small training data set and our meta
parameters and typically we just output
a single set of task specific parameters
Phi I
but there are cases where we might
actually want to fully represent the
distribution over top specific
parameters
um so for example you might have a few
shot learning problem where there's some
ambiguity
um so say for example you this is your
like a small training data set or a
small support set for a classifier we
have some positive examples on the left
some negative examples on the right
um and then say I gave you uh this
example right here
if you look at the attributes of the
positive examples and the negative
examples you might notice that everyone
in the positive examples of smiling and
everyone in the positive examples is
also wearing a hat uh and this person is
not smiling and they're wearing a hat
and so it's inherently ambiguous what
the correct label should be is is the
classifier supposed to pay attention to
um the facial expression is it supposed
to pay attention to whether they're
wearing a hat
um
and there might be another example like
this one where
um it's also somewhat ambiguous with
respect to like age maybe the classifier
is supposed to also be looking at the
age of the person
um so the source of ambiguity can come
up and we may want to not just output a
single classifier but actually output
multiple classifiers that might kind of
generate hypotheses underlying the data
that we see
um so yeah can we learn to generate
hypotheses about the underlying function
so that we can sample from this
distribution over top specific
parameters
and this ability to reason about
ambiguity might be important in a few
different settings it might be important
in really safety critical settings so if
you want to do something like Medical
Imaging then be useful to know if your
class if you're pretty confident about
the function that that you have or not
um it can also be important for active
learning settings so if you want to
figure out if you want to generate like
should you generate more examples or
more data points
um Can the basically can the algorithm
tell you yes I need more labels or no
I'm actually are pretty confident about
this example and there's actually a
number of works that I've looked at
Active Learning with meta learning
algorithms
and it can also be useful in meta
reinforcement learning as well if you
want to figure out how to explore a new
environment with a small amount of data
reasoning about the uncertainty that you
have can help you figure out what parts
of the environment to explore and what
parts of the environment
are already kind of you're already
sufficiently confident
okay
um so
those past few slides are a couple of
motivation for why we might want to
train more complex distributions and
then the rest of this lecture will
really be on actually trying to do that
cool
um so
let's start by looking at a couple
examples of latent variable models
and some of them might start with
examples that you've seen before
so say you have examples
um of some data points that look like
this and you want to fit a model to
these two's data points
if you just fit a gaussian to this you
probably wouldn't get a very good fit to
this data
and so what you might use instead is
something called a mixture model uh
where you try to fit um you have a few
different components and you have each
component is one component of your
mixture
uh and this would be an example of
something like a gaussian mixture model
uh where the underlying data points you
don't know the underlying structure in
which data points have
um correspond to which mixture component
but through the modeling process you
want to model both the mixture
components and the parameters of each
fixture component
and so mathematically the way that you
would write this down is something like
this where your mixture component is z
and your
[Music]
your kind of the parameters of each
mixture corresponds to P of x given Z
and in this particular case of a
gaussian mixture model P of Z would be a
categorical distribution and then P of x
given Z would be a conditional gaussian
distribution
cool
um so you may also have
um a conditional distribution that you
want to model also with something like a
mixture and to do that you can basically
just take the same gaussian mixture
model and condition everything on on the
variable that you're conditioning
um so this would now be
um instead of P to Z you would condition
your mixture element on on X so you'd
have P of Z given X and instead of
having your conditional gaussian
distribution only be conditioned on Z
you would also condition it on the
variable that you're conditioning on
which in this case is X
um and this is referred to something
it's really a I mean basically just a
conditional gaussian mixture model but
it has this fancy name of a mixture
density Network
um and so as an example of what this
might look like is if you want to
classify or if you want to regress to
the length of a paper given the title
then instead of just outputting like the
mean length that you think or the mean
and variance of the length of the paper
you'd actually output multiple mean
invariances and the weight of the
corresponding
um the corresponding gaussian
um and so uh typically for a standard
regression problem we may even only
output the mean just a single value
corresponding to the length of the paper
and this sort of model will actually
represent
um
kind of a much more Rich notion of of
what you think the label might be and
instead of outputting just one number
you would output n times three numbers
where where n is the number of mixture
components in your mixture model
all right so these are a couple examples
of latent variable models
now we can look at the more General case
so in general our goal with latent
variable models is to model a fairly
complicated distribution such as such as
the distribution here
and the way that we do that is first we
formulate a latent variable Z and it's
called latent because we don't observe Z
we only observe X we don't observe Z
and then we sample from that latent
variable this is going to be a
relatively simple distribution such as a
gaussian
and then we'll pass a sample from that
variable into a neural network that will
also be a pretty simple distribution as
well so this will also be a gaussian
distribution but the parameters of this
conditional gaussian distribution will
be fairly complex
and by essentially kind of taking this
Easy distribution and this Easy
distribution we can kind of compose them
to formulate a more complicated
distribution
basically we're going to be kind of
transforming samples from a gaussian
distribution with a neural network to
then give us samples from this more
complicated distribution
um and so the kind of general form of
this is
um this pretty simple equation right
here where we have our distribution over
our latent variable and our conditional
distribution of our example given our
latent variable
um and so in both of these cases PvZ is
going to be an easy or simple
distribution and P of x given Z is also
going to be a simple distribution class
and so really the key idea is that we
can represent this more complex
distribution by composing
to much more simple distributions
now it's worth mentioning that um
the
the P of x given Z I'm calling this a
simple distribution but the function
itself can be very complex
the function itself can be represented
by a neural network which is a pretty
complex function but the
um
the distribution class is really going
to be limited by the output distribution
which is a gaussian distribution and
your neural network is going to be
outputting the mean and variance of that
gaussian distribution
yeah so your ex-divency is always gonna
be like just that's always a gaussian
distribution and then so in order to get
that complicated distribution you kind
of this map
like kind of big differences that I
could get the corresponding piece in the
more complexity
yeah so you can basically think of like
um
the neural network will take kind of one
slice of this and then kind of map it on
to a particular slice of the top
distribution and it may give you it's
still going to
um
it's not just going to give you a single
value it will still give you a
distribution over that
um but it might be a it's going to be a
fairly simple distribution and so you
can imagine like mapping to like a small
gaussian right here for example
um and so yeah you can think of it as
taking samples from this and mapping it
to samples into that function
um so the question is with this setup
can you get any arbitrary distribution
over P of X
um
in general yes I don't know of um I
can't think of any distribution where
you wouldn't be able to represent it
um it does mean that there are some
distributions that will be harder to
represent than others if you have an
extremely discontinuous representation
it's hard for
um what's hard to also just like
optimize for those distributions in the
first place but
um
this does give you like really
considerable expressive power over
distributions
um the other thing that I'll note here
is that note that there's only one
neural network in this picture which is
the P of x given Z typically P of Z is
going to be a a gaussian distribution
and you don't even actually have to
learn the parameters of this gaussian
distribution you can just set it to be a
like a standard normal distribution with
zero mean and unit variance and that you
don't lose any generality by doing that
because the neural network can you can
like very easily take that and and
transform it into whatever it wants and
so if you could think of the first layer
as like picking a different mean and
variance for that and so that means that
you don't actually have to learn any
aspect of P of Z you only have to learn
P of x given Z
thank you
okay
um so now I have two questions for you
uh and in honor of of Halloween I have a
little bit of candy for people who ask
questions or who answer questions
um so the first question is
um once you train this neural network
how do you generate a sample from P of x
[Music]
Yeah so basically you can sample from
poz then pass that through your neural
network and then your neural network
will give you a mean and variance and
then you just sample from the gaussian
with that mean invariance and that will
then give you a sample from your
estimated P of x
so I I'm not very good at throwing
point one seed off
um cool
um and then the second question which is
a little bit harder than the first
question is um
now we have this model
um that we've trained
how do we evaluate the likelihood of a
given sample
so we just talked about how do we sample
something now instead of trying to
sample something we're actually just
given an X
and how do we evaluate
P of X for that given X
yeah do you want to
um
so you're saying that we could if x is
our example we can then integrate
[Music]
so you say we can draw a sample from Z
and then integrate or
no exist in the integral function from
the PHD are you just enforce eventual
the disc
yeah so what you could do is we have our
expression over here and so we could
sample a bunch of Z's and use that to
estimate this integral on the left and
that would give us an estimate for what
P of X is
cool so I will
do okay you're good okay I don't want to
disincentifies incorrect answers
cool
um so
um
you can estimate P of X and one thing
that's important that's worth noting
here is that actually evaluating P of x
like analytically is extremely difficult
because of this integral right here and
that's going to make training these
models also pretty difficult
Yeah question
is
[Music]
so can can you sample that and
um
[Music]
so you're asking we know that mean
squared error is equivalent to LOG
likelihood it's equivalent to LOG
likelihood for I think unit variance if
you don't basically learn the variance
and you're saying if we sample
um a z something from our model and then
measure mean squared error would that
give us likelihood you're saying
um
that would not
so if you only in general if you only
sample one thing you're not going to get
a very good estimate of it
um and so you might need a sample much
more than that
um the and yeah so generally if you're
not learning
um
but well so generally if you're not
learning the variance you might be able
to do something like that but
um
the really the correct thing to do is to
kind of try to evaluate or estimate that
integral right there and you might get a
form that if you don't learn the
variance of certain things you might get
a form that looks like mean squared r
[Music]
yeah so once you actually
um so log likelihood corresponds to mean
squared error if you have unit variance
and if you learn the variance that it
ends up being a weighted mean squared
error
um and so there is
um
there is basically that sort of
equivalence and it'll once you actually
start to write out that equation
um for gaussian distributions you will
get something that looks like
um like a weighted mean squirter
cool
um so
this gets into how we can train latent
variable models
um and
we know that we have this likelihood
function uh and so we know that um sorry
we know that P of X is the integral of P
of x given Z times P of Z
and so if we wanted to
go about training these models we could
um basically
plug in
um
plug in this P of X into our equation
right there and so our objective would
be kind of summing over our data points
or averaging over data our data points
of log of the integral of P of x given Z
times P of Z
uh DZ
and so we could try to go about
optimizing
um
optimizing for this this equation right
here
but unfortunately generally
um you need to sample a lot of these in
order to actually
accurately estimate this integral
and so in general this integral isn't
going to be particularly tractable
and if we needed to optimize if you need
to like every single time we take a
gradient step we need to sample a ton of
different Z's then
um
we wouldn't be able to optimize this
particularly easily
and so that's where
um that's where these all these kind of
different techniques for training latent
variable models come in is they want to
basically try to
um estimate the the gradient of this
objective without having to evaluate the
integral
um so there's a number of different
flavors of latent variable models and
um in the Deep learning literature and
they basically all just come down to
different ways to train these kinds of
latent variable models
um and so you may have heard of things
like generative adversarial networks
variational autoencoders normalizing
flow models and diffusion models
and all of these models are just
different examples of different latent
variable models they all have some sort
of latent variable that's typically uh I
guess actually in all these cases I
think it's a typically a gaussian latent
variable that's then transformed with
the neural network into
into the the original into the space of
the examples
um there's one class of narrative models
that does not use latent variables and
this is auto regressive models
um you saw these in the generative
pre-training lecture uh but basically
every everything else that I know of
uses a form of latent variable
um and really the way that these
different
um latent variable models differ is how
they are trained and they have different
different pros and cons in terms of the
ability to optimize them and the ability
to evaluate likelihoods of samples and
so forth
um in this lecture and um and also on
Wednesday we're really going to focus on
methods that use variational inference
to train them
um primarily because that's
um it it has a number of benefits and it
also is what's been used most for uh
latent variable models over parameters
in meta learning however there's also
um
like lots of hybrids of these models as
well where variational inference becomes
quite useful like there are papers that
combine via using cans there are
variational diffusion models and there's
also connections between variational
inference and normalizing flow models as
well
[Music]
what is a good example of latent
variables um that's a great question so
the
in general oftentimes when you train the
latent variable model
the latent variables don't necessarily
have any particular interpretable
meaning to them
in the case of the mixture models that
we saw the latent variable corresponded
to the different mixture components and
in some cases that might have a natural
kind of interpretable meaning if your
data naturally has those different
clusters then basically the the latent
variable will correspond to the identity
of of that cluster and in this example
the kind of the face attribute example
that we saw different latent variables
if you were to try to generate
um
images like that different latent
variables might correspond to different
attributes and if you're trying to train
a classifier
um and basically generate these
different classifiers then different
latent variables would correspond to
like different combinations of
attributes that that classifier is
paying attention to
um so ideally that's that's the kind of
thing that we want these latent
variables to correspond to
um there's a question of whether the
model will actually learn those things
in practice and it can use the
um
the latent variables to really
correspond to whatever it wants the
other thing that I'll mention on this
topic is that
um especially in the context of
conditional latent variable models for
example if you're training something to
predict why
um
y given X where Z is your latent
variable then the latent variable is
basically the only source of Randomness
or the only source of information other
than your input X and so
um Z or the latent variable needs to
capture
things in y that can't be found in x
cool
um so now let's try to talk about how we
can actually train these models like how
do we yeah train these models to to
generate pretty pictures or parameters
or whatever
uh and so an outline of what we're going
to talk about is first we're going to
formulate a bound on the log likelihood
objective that will allow us to get away
from
Computing that annoying integral then
we're going to check how tight the bound
is
and then we're going to
move towards amortized variational
inference which is a kind of important
practical step that's important in deep
latent variable models and lastly we'll
talk about how to actually optimize the
bound that we have
cool so
um we want to go about optimizing the
subjective and we're going to formulate
a slightly different objective called
the expected log likelihood
and on this slide I'm not going to
justify this objective this is mostly
for just trying to build some intuition
for what we're going to be doing on the
next slide
and in particular
um what this kind of expected log
likelihood it looks a lot like this
but we've now replaced the integral with
an expectation
uh over the latent variable given the
input X
and the intuition here is that
um essentially we don't
um when we have this integral we're kind
of considering all possible values of z
um and really the ones that are relevant
for optimizing this function are the Z's
that are most likely for a given x i
we don't want to have to consider all
possible
all possible Z's we want to consider the
ones that are actually going to be most
likely corresponding to an x i
of course there isn't just a single
um single Z for a given X either may
actually be multiple possible values of
your latent variable and so we're going
to be using this distribution of Z given
x i which is often referred to as the
posterior distribution
um and once we can kind of consider
these possible values of
um of Z and then maximize for the
um this kind of joint likelihood for
that Z and our sample X
um the subjective it becomes a lot
easier to optimize because we can
estimate that expectation using samples
um and so
once we have this objective it's pretty
nice although there's still this
question of how do we actually estimate
Z given x i
um that's not something that we're
really given a priority
um
and so
if you think about first
um what Z given x i looks like maybe for
this particular value of x the
corresponding Z might have this
distribution right here
um what we're going to try to do is
we're going to try to estimate this
distribution of Z given x i with
something fairly simple
so we'll estimate it with uh with what
I'll call qi
and basically for every single data
point we're going to try to estimate
what we think
the latent variable is and that will be
represented by this Q variable here so
instead of instead of actually having
the true Z of x i we're going to
estimate it with something that looks
like a gaussian distribution
now this estimate isn't going to be
perfect and so as you saw on the slide
uh these two distributions weren't
exactly the same but once we have this
estimate it will help us
um with optimizing the objective
so
um
the thing that's nice about actually
trying to approximate Z given x i with
something like Qi is that
um once we have this estimate of the
latent variable for a particular data
point it means that we can formulate a
bound on our objective
um and the bound is is um
is not to
difficult to formulate
so the um
we want to formulate
um
a
a bound on P of x i or log P of x i so
this is the log likelihood for a single
data point
um in reality we would actually be
summing over all of our data points but
I'm just going to remove the sums for
Simplicity of notation
and like we've talked about before this
is equal to the integral over
um
sorry this is equal to the log of the
integral of um
P of x i given Z times P of Z DZ
and um
now there's a question of where this
kind of Qi will come into play
and one thing that you could do whenever
you want to uh
introduce new distributions is or new
variables into your equation is
basically take your expression and
multiply it by uh
sorry Qi of Z
divided by q i of Z
and this is okay to do because this is
always going to be equal to one and so
we're just multiplying
the inside by 1.
and once we have this we can then
formulate this is an expectation so this
is equal to the log of the expectation
of
q i of Z sample from qi of everything on
the inside so we get p of x i given Z
times P of Z
divided by q i of Z
and this is a much nicer form than what
we had before
because we know how to sample from Qi Qi
is a distribution is gaussian
distribution that we're estimating right
there
uh and so
we now can
um yeah we now basically have something
that we can sample from instead of
trying to evaluate the integral
um so all I've done here is this is just
kind of algebra up until this point we
actually haven't made any approximations
yet
and it's worth noting that we can
actually this kind of holds true
basically for any Qi we aren't making
any assumptions on how good Qi is
cool um and then from here uh what we
can do is it's annoying to have an
expectation inside of a log uh because
we want we want the expectation to be on
the outside so that we can sample
um and estimate sample mini batches
rather than sampling a ton of different
Z
and this is where Jensen's inequality
can come in which we saw previously
um and in this case Jensen's inequality
will actually work in our favor
um rather than rather than hurting us so
Jensen's inequality
um
says that uh
blog of expectation of some variable Y
is greater than or equal to the
expectation of the log of Y
I should also mention actually that
judson's inequalities actually
it's actually a lot more General than
this it actually holds for any concave
function so log is an example of one
concave function but you can plug in any
other concave function other than log
and um it also kind of showed the same
sort of bound also if you have a convex
function it's also the same you just
need to flip the sign of the of the
inequality
and so with
Jensen's inequality we can now
um
formulate a lower bound
on our objective I basically just like
swapping the order of the expectation
and the log
and because these are products we can
then start to actually write these out
as a sum of logs rather than a log of
the product so log of P of x i given Z
Plus
log of P of Z
minus log
of q i of Z
um
and this is basically
basically now we're objective so
this is something that we can now
optimize so we'll sample a z from the
distribution Qi for that data point and
maximize the likelihood of the data
point
of x i conditioned on that value of Z
we'll also
optimize for log of P of Z under um for
this value and then lastly we'll also
get this last term and this actually
this last term with the expectation
corresponds to the entropy of
Q of Z
now this whole objective is um
is called the evidence lower bound
or the elbow
and let's try to talk a little bit
through some of the intuition behind the
subjective
so
um
this is basically just writing out what
I wrote out on the board
and
and also kind of writing it out in terms
of with judson's inequality so this is
the the kind of final bound
um and once you maximize this objective
that means that you're also maximizing
our original objective which is the log
likelihood
um so
to talk a little bit about the intuition
I think it's helpful to first talk about
um some quantities like entropy and kale
Divergence so
entropy is something that we've kind of
talked about before but we haven't
formally gone over and it's defined as
the negative
um
log probability under basically the
negative expected log probability which
is equal to the negative integral of P
of X log P of x
and there's a couple different
intuitions behind what entropy
corresponds to
the first is basically how random a
variable is
and so for example if you think about
the
um a coin flip like a Bernoulli variable
uh if the weight of that coin is 0.5
that means that it's more random and the
entropy measures that uh whereas if it's
uh the kind of probability of heads is
one then it has zero entropy because it
doesn't have any randomness
so you can essentially think of entropy
as measuring how much Randomness does
this variable have
and the other way to look at it is
thinking about how large is the log
probability of the variable in
expectation under itself
and so if you have two different
distributions
in expectation this one has
um High log probabilities and this one
has a lot of low
log probabilities and if you have a
small log
um sorry this one has high probabilities
this one has low probabilities and
something with low probabilities will
have the log of that will be a large
negative number whereas the log of
something with a higher probability will
be a a small negative number and so the
thing that has large negative numbers
will have a large entropy
and the the one that has
um
these high probabilities which
correspond to these small the small log
probabilities will have a low entropy
um and so if we think about the
objective that we just talked about
right here which is the evidence lower
bound it has really two main terms in it
um
and the first term so if we try to plot
as a function of z p of x i comma Z and
we draw a sample from Q
you can think of the first part or
basically the first two terms here
I was saying okay for a given Z my
probability of X comma Z should be high
and so that's going to basically
um
pick something like that it tries to
pick a z that it has high P of X comma Z
and then what the second term is going
to try to do is it's going to try to
maximize the entropy of Q of Z and so
it's going to try to basically make the
distribution as wide as possible
and so overall what this objective is
going to do is it has really these two
parts one that's maximizing probability
and one that's trying to make that
distribution as wide as possible such
that you're matching the underlying
distribution
any questions on entropy or this
intuition
cool so
um the second thing that we can look at
is What's called the kale Divergence
and this is also something that I think
we've seen briefly and the kale
Divergence between the two distributions
is defined as the expectation under one
of those distributions of the log of the
ratio of the first distribution divided
by the second distribution
um and you can kind of equivalently
write this out
as the negative probability of one
distribution under the other minus the
entropy of that other distribution
um and again there's two different ways
to intuitively look at the kale
Divergence the first is thinking about
how different are these two
distributions how different is Q from p
um and you can see that for example when
Q equals p uh the killed evidence will
be zero because when when Q equals P
that ratio on the left will be one and
then the log of one is zero and so this
will be uh
zero and as they become more and more
different the kale Divergence will grow
and then the second way that we can look
at it especially looking at this
equation right here is
um basically how small is the expected
log probability of one distribution
under the other distribution
um minus the entropy and so
this ends up giving us a similar picture
to before where if we think about the
probability of one distribution under
the other that will
basically give us the kind of like
um
maximizing that will maximize or
minimizing that will maximize this first
part uh and then
the entry people will also try to
maximize it and so if you want to try to
minimize the kale Divergence this is
going to try to make the distributions
as similar as possible
okay so
um up until this point we've kind of
derived an objective for
um for optimizing these latent variable
models and the way that we do that the
way that we did that is we
we still have our kind of our P of Z
term which is just can be like a
gaussian distribution like a standard
normal distribution
and we have our our neural network
that's kind of mapping from a z to an x
i and then We additionally introduced
this um
this third thing which is
um this kind of distribution that's
trying to approximate
um
the posterior is trying to approximate P
of Z given x i
um
and so then the next question is um
we bounded this objective
um is this bound actually tight and in
which cases is this bound actually tight
um and part of this relates to the
question of
the choice of qi
and what makes a Qi and really the
intuition is that we want Qi to be as
close as possible to P of Z given x i we
want to basically be able to tell us the
distribution over the latent variable
for a given example
[Music]
um you're asking can you
um can I tell you when would Qi not be
equal to this
um
[Music]
why would it be evil
because
yeah so you're a little bit ahead of me
so basically if um if Qi is equal to P
of Z given x i it turns out the bound
will be tight
and
um
in particular uh if if their kale
Divergence is minimized if the cable
Divergence is zero then the bound will
be tight and there is I guess
there's a question of do I want to go on
this on whiteboard or on the sides
um
I feel like it'd be just a little bit
faster to go over on the slides and that
might it might be nice to do that so
um
to answer your question we can basically
look at the kale Divergence between Qi
and P of Z given x i and derive what
this actually corresponds to
and we can do this by just first writing
out the equation for kale Divergence
which is the expectation of Q of log Q
over p
and
with Bayes rule or if we multiply the
top and bottom by P of x i we get an
expression that looks like this
um
and then if we kind of expand out the
law the log of the product into to the
sum of logs we get
um
the negative log of the bottom which is
p of x i given Z and P of Z Plus the log
of the top which is the log of q i of Z
and the log of
P of x
and
um this starts to look pretty familiar
so the first three or
um
basically this is equal to the entropy
and everything before this this last
part is exactly equal to the evidence
lower bound
um and so
the um what this means is that
if you set the kale Divergence equal to
zero
if we set q i of Z equal to P of Z given
x i then
Li is equal to the log probability
and so that means that basically the the
bound is tight they're about the the
loss function or the evidence lower
abound is exactly equal to the log
likelihood when the kale Divergence
between q i of Z and P of Z given x i is
zero
um
cool um and also because the kale
Divergence is always non-negative
um this also kind of is another way to
derive the bound on P of x i
um and so this this bound essentially
um instead of using Jensen's inequality
it's just relying on the fact that the
kale divergences uh
is non-negative
um
cool so if the kill Divergence is zero
then that means our evidence lower bound
is tight and that means that we are
um if we kind of basically exactly
represent P of Z given x i then we're
going to be exactly maximizing the
likelihood
um the second thing to note here is that
um so so far we've talked about kind of
how we're going to be optimizing this
neural network the other question is how
do we optimize for qi
and if we optimize for Qi with respect
to
um the same lower bound
then what that's going to do is that's
going to be minimizing the kale
Divergence because
um
I guess I can write this out right here
so we saw that the
um
the kale Divergence between uh
q i of Z and P of Z given x i is equal
to our loss function plus log
P of x i
actually sorry negative
yeah
um
and so basically if we
if we decide to maximize
Li with respect to q i
um
this this doesn't depend on Qi at all
and so
um
that means that if we maximize L this
corresponds to minimizing this left hand
side which means that we're minimizing
the kale Divergence and that's a really
good thing because if we're minimizing
the kale Divergence with respect to q
that means that we're making the bound
tighter
uh and so this really justifies using
optimizing this evidence lower bound
both with respect to Theta as well as
with respect to Q because it means that
we're going to be optimizing a bound and
we're going to be making that bound
tighter as well
foreign
cool um and so what are optimization
objective will look like is basically we
have this single objective
um Li and we're going to maximize it
both with respect to our model
parameters Theta and with respect to our
What's called the variational
distribution qi
okay so then there's a question of
actually
um kind of walking through what the
algorithm looks like
so once we have this objective uh the
first step will be to sample
an example X I uh or a mini batch of
examples
then we want to compute the gradient uh
with respect to Theta
of Li
and the way that we'll do actually
yeah does anyone want to actually
say how do we compute the gradient of
this with respect to Theta
or what the first step is
so you can see Theta appears
um just right here and that's the only
the only place where Theta appears
[Music]
so you're saying that we could take the
gradient inside
um so we sampled an x i but to evaluate
the gradient of this we need both an x i
and a z
um so where do we get the Z from
example
the most possible the most likely
the Z given X because here's our legs
late because the image of disease is
most likely you're likely the soft
objective
yeah so so what we'll do is I'm not
fully sure if this is what you're
suggesting but what we can do is we can
um we have qi
and so we can sample a z or or multiple
Z's from qi
uh and then once we have those Z's then
we can
um use that to kind of pass that into
here and compute the gradient of log P
Theta using those uh using those Z's and
so yeah well basically first sample
um
first sample Z from
q i
uh
and then once we have the Z we can then
um
basically kind of compute the gradient
of log
P Theta of x i given that Z
in practice uh typical well I'm only
writing a single sample here uh
typically
if you want to like get an extremely
accurate gradient then you would sample
multiple Z's from here but in practice
actually just sampling one often works
just fine
cool and I feel like I should
it's also pretty far so I'm not sure how
well I could throw yeah
so using this onesie does their sort of
implicitly assume that I did
does it implicitly assume that our data
is what I'm sorry
[Music]
um so the question is uh by only
sampling one Z does that implicitly
assume that our data is well behaved
um
I'm not sure what well-behaved means
the expectation would eventually correct
itself
over
right so I think that um
I think that one of the reasons why it
works well is we're modeling Qi as a
gaussian distribution and gaussian
distributions are
fairly simple
and unimodal and so I think that for
that reason because gaussian
distributions are well behaved perhaps
the set using just one sample is is okay
um
but I yeah I'm not sure if I have a
better answer than that
um if we had a beta distribution rather
than the gaussian
um well we haven't yet I guess we
haven't yet gotten to the the training
the QI part but
um
it would have been it'd be hard to train
a beta distribution
um you can measure the entropy of a
gaussian distribution in closed form
with respect to the mean and variance of
that so that becomes a lot easier uh
specifically with respect to this step
um I'm not sure I've never tried it in
part because of the complexity there but
um I could see it being possible like
possibly needing more samples in that
case
yeah
do we have one try per excite or
is it multiple choices yeah so so far we
have one Qi for every x i
um
we will do that soon it's a great idea
was there a question
um
right so the question is for prediction
do we still sample multiple Z's so
um it depends on how you're using it uh
the if you're just generating from the
model you're actually not going to be
sampling from Q at all you'll be
sampling from p p of Z and then passing
that through your neural network
um if you do want to get a really good
like
um
if you do want to get a better estimate
one thing you can do is sample and then
take the
um basically sample and then take the
max or something like that and Sample
multiple times so there are things that
you can do to sample
um more than once at at inference time
it kind of depends on how you're using
it though in the case of variational
Auto encoders you actually very rarely
use Q at test time you often just throw
it away at test time and only just use
it to generate samples but there are
other cases where you may actually be
using Queue at test time
cool
um so oh
we got through step two
um which is how to compute the gradient
and then the last thing that we'll want
to do is to update
uh
qi
with respect to
the loss function
uh and the way that we'll do this is if
Qi is a gaussian distribution then
um
we can set basically Qi to be a gaussian
distribution with a mean of mu I and a
variance of Sigma I
and then basically compute the gradient
of
um your loss function with respect to Mu
I and also the gradient with respect to
Sigma I
and
then use that to update mui and sigma I
and so this will basically this is
basically just what's written out on the
slide so
um we estimate the gradient it's an
estimate if you only take one sample
and although even if you take a few
samples it's still an estimate unless
you take an infinite number of samples
and then we'll update Qi and the way
that we do that is we'll evaluate the
gradient of the mean and the gradient of
the variance
cool
um so this already sort of came up but
there's a little bit of a problem here
um which is that in typically in deep
learning we have a large number of
samples
and that means that it may be somewhat
impractical to fit a Qi for every single
example
um and so one question is when we have
this kind of model what is the total
number of parameters
yeah so first you have all the data and
then you also have a set of we have big
and many sets of the
our needs a very basilic DUI and sigma
heart yeah exactly so we'll have all of
our Theta and we'll have one of those
and then for the number of examples that
we have we'll have
[Music]
um
two times the dimensionality of or well
n times the dimensionality of mu and N
times the dimensionality of
um of Sigma
and so this is a lot pretty large number
of parameters
um so to solve this problem what we can
do which was actually already suggested
which is that instead of having a single
Qi for every single data point we can
train a neural network to predict Z
given x i
um and
uh so instead of only having a neural
network that predicts x given Z we're
going to have a second Network which is
often called an inference Network
to
give you a distribution over Z given X
um
and this neural network will give it'll
take his input X and it'll output a mean
and a variance
and so Q will again be a gaussian
distribution but it'll be a conditional
gaussian distribution and this neural
network is outputting the mean in the
variance and then the normal
distribution is parametrized by that
mean in that variance
um cool so this is where we get to
amortize variational inference and the
reason why it's called amortized
variational inferences where essentially
amortizing the inference process across
using this neural network
um rather than just having like doing
inference for every single data point
individually
um cool and so
the way this works is we again will
formulate the same exact objective
except instead of being Qi of Z we'll
just replace that with Q Phi of Z given
x i
um
and this works out with the bound
because
we mentioned that this works really for
any value of Q and so it can be
um Q can be conditioned on x i it could
really be conditioned on whatever you
want it to be conditioned on uh and so
it's natural for it to be conditioned on
x i because we want to be very similar
to poz given x i
um cool and then the algorithm ends up
looking
uh the same as before except now
um instead of sampling from Qi
um or
um sorry q i over Z we're now going to
be sampling over this conditional
distribution that's conditioned on x i
and then instead of updating each of the
individual qis we're going to be
updating the parameters of our inference
Network which I'm using Phi to denote
cool and so that's all written right
here and we can take a gradient descent
step on Phi
now there's one more problem
that we have to fix
which is actually how do we end up
calculating this gradient right here
um and the the reason why this is a
problem is that if we look at our
objective
[Music]
um
there's a few different places where Phi
will come up
so Phi will come up right here
and Phi will also come up right here
and this part isn't too hard to
calculate you can look up there's a
closed form equation of the entropy of a
gaussian that you can look up
um but this one ends up being a little
bit more difficult because here you
actually have to differentiate through
the sampling process into Phi
um so this part is easy
um the second part is a little bit
harder
and
in terms of going into this we'll um
refer to this inside part it doesn't
really matter what this inside part is
we'll refer to it as R of x i given Z
and then our goal is to be able to
compute the gradient with respect to Phi
of this expectation
of Q Phi of our
of x i comma Z so this is our goal this
is what we want to be able to compute
um and
Q is going to be outputting a gaussian
distribution
now
this is where What's called the
re-parametrization trick comes in
and so in particular
um
qfi of Z given X this is defined to be a
gaussian distribution of some neural
network that takes as input X
and the variants that take spins input X
and
um
we here we're going to be sampling in
this expectation a z from
this uh
from this uh
our our Q distribution
and we want to be able to differentiate
through this sampling process
and the really cool thing about what's
called the reparametrization trick is we
can rewrite this
this equation the sampling process as
the equation mu of x
plus Epsilon times Sigma of X where
Epsilon is a
gaussian Epsilon is a variable that's or
Epsilon is the value that is sampled
from a standard normal distribution
um and so this this equation should be
fairly straightforward so we're just
saying that a sample from a gaussian
distribution equals the mean plus some
noise times the variance
and the really cool thing about this
equation is that
[Music]
um
Epsilon is completely independent
of Phi
um whereas the MU and sigma are
parameterized by Phi and that means that
we can
basically generated a sample this way
where we generate a sample from Epsilon
and then plug it into this equation
and then
that gives us a sample and we can
differentiate through this equation into
Phi in order to update Phi through the
sampling process
and so more concretely
um
this is the equation that I wrote up on
the board Z equals mu plus Epsilon times
Sigma
we can first sample Sigma or sorry we
can first sample Epsilon in a way that's
completely independent of the inference
Network parameters
multiply that by Sigma
and add in the mean and then in order to
compute the gradient of this expression
um now we no longer actually have to
sample from Q we can instead sample from
the standard normal distribution
and this equation is much easier to
differentiate through
in comparison to the first equation
and so basically to estimate the
gradient of
Phi we first sample a bunch of samples
from the standard normal distribution
a single sample actually also can work
well in this case and then
the gradient will be approximately equal
to the gradient of Phi of
of R where we plug in this equation for
our sample for for Z
cool any questions on how that works
I should mention this it's really
important that this is independent of
Phi
right so um if this is Vector value then
this will be uh identity
something like is there like a
um
yeah so the question is are we losing
anything by doing amortized
um by doing amortization
um
it's a good question uh I think that the
I think the only thing that we may be
really losing in this case is that the
your you essentially have something that
may be slightly
uh in practice I don't think this is
really the case but when when you
actually like separately represent each
Qi you can really represent like just a
gaussian for all of them and you
um
you have a lot of expressive power
whereas when you have a single neural
network that has to Output
um a different Z for every X for a given
X it has to be able to look at X and
then tell you what Z is and it may it
may be somewhat difficult to do that
with a single function it may also be
that x i
um there are two exercises that look
very different but actually have very
different latent variables and in cases
like that
um it may be
it may be especially difficult for the
inference Network to do that but
[Music]
um
so yeah but really just being able to
represent that
um being able to represent Q of Z given
X like you have to be able to represent
that but I think that's really the only
thing that you're you're losing
I guess I could also mention that there
are some works that um kind of amortize
and then run some additional gradient
steps on z uh and you can they're kind
of like more hybrid methods um as well
that you can that you can consider
thank you
cool um so for the reproversation trick
uh it's really like super easy to
implement uh
and it's also gives you a pretty low
variance estimate of your gradient
um it only works for continuous latent
variables uh one specifically in this
case gaussian random variables
uh if you are really excited about
having discrete latent variables then
there are techniques for optimizing for
those so there's something called the
straight through estimator and Vector
quantization that has been used in
conjunction with variational auto
encoders we won't go into it here but
it's something that's been pretty
successful with discrete latent
variables and you could also use
something called the reinforced trick
which is also policy gradients which are
often often used in reinforcement
learning but also can be used to
estimate gradients here
um but for continuous latent variables
three parameterization trick is is far
better than uh than these options
cool
um
in the last five minutes
um I like to also kind of go over
another interpretation of the objective
so we've talked about the objective as
um
as basically kind of an entropy term and
like a likelihood term
and alternatively there's a different
way to look at it
and the other way that you can look at
it
is um
is if you combine this term in this term
you end up getting q log uh
expectation of q log p and minus
expectation of q log q and these two
terms combined actually correspond to
the kale Divergence
and
um specifically the kale Divergence
between uh
Q Z given X and P of Z
and then you're just left with you also
still have this first term which is the
expectation of z
um
sampled from Q of log
uh P Theta
of
x i given Z
and
um this is basically a separate way to
look at the
um at the equation
and
um actually sorry this should be a minus
sign
and
this way you can
um
you can sort of think of this from the
standpoint of an auto encoder where your
Q network is encoding your example into
this latent space and your model P of x
given Z is decoding from your latent
variable back into your space so if you
think of the autoencoders that we saw
before then you can think of the encoder
as Q of Z give it X and the decoder as P
of x given Z
and then from this standpoint
this term right here
you first encode and then you evaluate
the likelihood of under your decoder and
this basically corresponds to
reconstruction error like how good are
you at reconstructing the example after
you've encoded it and decoded it
and then the second term is telling you
that once you encode
um your example into your Z space this
should look like a like a gaussian
distribution
so
um yeah your z's basically should be
gaussian distributed and this is going
to
um
then basically add noise into this um
into this variable right here and that
will kind of force the model to not be
able to represent the identity function
through your encoder and decoder
um so the kale diverges also has a
convenient analytical form for gaussian
distributions
um
and the
yeah so you can basically think of this
as taking an x outputting a mean
invariance over Z
then adding noise or sampling from Q in
order to generate a z sample
and then decoding that Z sample with
your P of data to generate an X
cool um and this basically corresponds
to the variational autoencoder and you
can basically kind of sample a z from a
gaussian space like a low dimensional
gaussian space and then have your
decoder or your kind of your model P of
x given Z then generate some cool
looking faces for you yeah
yeah exactly so you can think of the
kale term as acting as a regularizer on
the autoencoder so that you're not only
optimizing for reconstruction you're
also
um encouraging it to kind of regularize
the information content in z
um
cool yeah
what does variational mean
um so
I don't know if it has any meaning in
English uh but the
um the distribution queue uh of Z this
is often referred to as the variational
distribution
um maybe in the sense that it is kind of
um it's not the true distribution it's
not it's not the kind of the
distribution given by your model it's
not it's not like the true distribution
for example
okay
Maybe
yeah I come from calculus of variations
yes that's possible
cool
um
and then when you want to sample from a
variational auto encoder you can first
sample Z and then sample x given z
um
and yeah
um lastly if you want to do conditional
models you can also condition on
um something we we primarily didn't we
talked about unconditional models to
start but you could also basically
condition your inference Network and
condition your model on something like a
class variable to generate images of
that class
um or text and so forth
um and so really everything is the same
we're just conditioning on some input
value
cool
um so that's it uh to summarize we
talked about latent variable models how
to train them with variational inference
and amortize variational inference
um and we learned about various things
like the reparametrization trick to
optimize the these kinds of models
um yeah and as a reminder homework 3 is
due on Friday and I'll see folks on
Wednesday